[موسيقى]
من هذا اليوم من التطورات في باكستان حيث
نقل مراسل الجزيره عن مصادر تاكيدها
اقتحام رجال الشرطه منزل عمران خان في
لاهور وقالت حركه الانصاف الباكستانيه ان
الشرطه نفذت اسوا مشاهد العنف خلال دخول
منزل عمران خان في لاهور وفي هذه الاثناء
نقل مراسلنا عن مسؤول في حكومه اقليم
البنجاب ان الشرطه ستعمل مع الاداره
المدنيه لازاله خيام مؤقته كان مؤيد خان
قد نصبوها في محيط منزله واقاموا فيها
بطريقه عشوائيه وغير قانونيه التصدي لقوات
الامن التي كانت تحاول اعتقاله الاسبوع
الماضي ونقلت وكاله الانباء نيمرا خان
قوله ان هناك تهديدا اكبر لحياته اكثر من
ذي قبل واضاف ان الخصومه السياسيين
والمؤسسه العسكريه يحاولون منعه من العوده
الى السلطه كما وجه خ ان رساله لمؤيده من
داخل سيارته بعد خروجه من لاهور حذرهم
فيها من وجود مخطط لاعتقاله في اسلام اباد
اريد ان يعرف الجميع ان هناك مخططا متكامل
الاركان الاعتقالي وهو ما يثبت سوءانيه من
وضع المخطط فانا اصلا كنت سامثل امام
المحكمه ومحاوله اعتقال سابقه من منزلي لم
تكن لجلب الى المحكمه بل لوضع في السجن
وهذا عمل بمخطط شرير وضعه نواز شريف في
لندن لمنع من المشاركه في الانتخابات ورغم
معرفه بنيه المبيته الاعتقال سامثل امام
المحكمه للتاكيد على ايمان بالقضاء وبسلطه
القانون وايضا لكشف وفضح مخطط المجرمين
الذين يتحكمون في البلد ومن وضعهم في هذا
الموقع والذين يريدون تحكيم قانون الغاب
هذه التطورات تزامنا مع مثول خان امام
محكمه ابتدائيه للنظر في قضيه في قضيه
تصرفه بطريقه غير قانونيه في مجموعه هدايا
ثمينه تلقاها خلال رئاسته للحكومه وكانت
محكمه اساء هذا العليا قد منعت الشرطه من
محاوله اعتقال خان اثناء تنقله بين لاهور
والعاصمه اصابات هذا واعلنت الاداره
المدنيه للعاصمه فرض قانون منع التجمعات
وامرت بنقل مقر محاكمه عمران خان من مجمع
المحاكم الابتدائيه الى المجمع القضائي
الذي تم نشر اعداد اضافيه من قوات الامن
في محيطه كما صدرت الاداره تعليمات بضروره
وصول خان ومحاميه الى المجمع القضائي دون
غيرهم وقد اعلنت سلطه العاصمه فرض حاله
الطوارئ في المستشفيات وطلبت في زمن
الهدوء والتعاون معها وعدم الحاق الضرر
بالممتلكات العامه والخاصه
معنى من لاهور مدير مكتبه الجزيره عبد
الرحمن مطر عبد الرحمن ما الذي علم بخصوص
هذا الاقتحام اقتحام الشرطه لمنزل عمران
خان في لاهور وما يجري خلال هذه اللحظات
مريم اقتحام الشرطه لمنزل عمران خان في
لاهور كان بحجه تعرض افراد الشرطه لاطلاق
نار من داخل المنزل ما استدعى جلب اليه
ثقيله لتحطيم البوابه الرئيسيه
لمنزل عمران خان وبالفعل دخل رجال الشرطه
الى الداخل ووقع اشتباك محدود مع عدد من
مؤيدي عمران خان ومن العاملين داخل المنزل
لكن قبل ان يتم كل ذلك كانت الشرطه قد
اغلقت بالكامل كافه الطرق المؤيده الى
الحيه السكني هنا في الهور الذي يقطن فيه
عمران خان ويسمح فقط
لمن يسكنون في الحي السكني بالدخول الى
المنطقه بينما انه لا يسمح لاحد اخر لدخول
على المنطقه المعلم كان من جانب الشرطه ان
مؤيدين عمران خان كانوا قد وضعوا خلال
الايام القليله الماضيه بعض المتاريس وعدد
من الخيامه المؤقته في المنطقه السكنيه في
محيط منزل عمران خانه شخصيا وانه لابد من
البلد هذه العشوائيات وهذه الخيام وكان
بالفعل هناك عمليه لازاله كل تلك
العشوائيات التي اقامها
المتاريس من اكياس التراب الثقيله التي
وضعها هناك خلال تنفيذ عمليه التطهير كما
تسمى هنا بلغه الشرطه تعرض افرادها
للاطلاق دارما استدعى دخولهم الى المنزل
واشتباكهم مع عدد من مؤيدين عمران خان عدد
خليل حقيقه
وكل هذه العمليه تمت بعد مغادره خان لاهور
متوجها الى العاصمه امام القاضي في
المحكمه هناك عمران خان شخصيا كان قد كتب
ايضا على موقعه في على حسابي في موقع
تويتر بان لا يوجد احد داخل المنزل الا
زوجته وبعض من مؤيدين وانه من غير لائق
ولا يوجد حجه لدى الشرطه الاقتحام المنزل
لكن على كل حال الشرطه بالفعل اقتحمت
المنزل وحطمت الب
علمنا ايضا بان على الاقل ثلاثه من مؤيدي
عمران خان مما كانوا داخل المنزل تم
ايقافهم حاليا للتحقيق معهم بشان اطلاق
النار الذي تعرض له الشرطه ربما هناك بعض
من اعمال التفتيش ايضا التي تتم الان داخل
المنزل انتقاد كبير من جانب حزب انصاف ومن
قياده الحزب لهذه العمليه التي نفذتها
الشرطه اليوم هنا في لاهورت وتحديدا فيما
يتعلق باقتحام منزل عمران
كنت معنا من لاهور